everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're going
to finish that component that we started
yesterday so if you didn't see yesterday
stream don't worry we'll kind of go
through what we'll go over a little bit
about what we did yesterday but if you
want to see it from the beginning you
can always watch the recording later on
but today we'll we'll finish building
out that component a bit make it look
nice and then we'll actually make it its
own component right now it exists within
a much larger component but we want to
put it somewhere else and we'll also
grab some some data and plug in some
real data and see how that how that
looks all right so let me get my my view
situated here and I'm a paste in this
link
all right so just pasted a link in a
live chat that link will take you to the
website and so that you can look at what
we're doing you know while you're while
we're doing it so it's hosted on my
computer and it's using a service called
an grub so that you all can click on it
as well Oh
Aniki says in a live chat just saying hi
gonna go watch the football match
alright thanks for saying hi Stevens
here sis what's up awesome Michaels here
great I asked nice alright cool so it
looks like yeah we're getting a few more
viewers I didn't realize I'd be
competing with with one of the football
matches so who knows maybe I won't get
that many viewers okay Phoenix says was
watching the Elector skill dev
livestream before oh cool how how was
that livestream I didn't get to catch it
live yesterday because I was streaming
and then today I didn't get to catch it
either is it is it finished drought I
wanted to start when that finished so
yesterday I didn't realize what was
happening so we overlapped but I'm gonna
try to avoid the overlap for the rest of
the week for those of you who don't know
what I'm talking about there's another
livestream going on this week on the
free code camp channel and that
livestream is all about creating an
Alexa skill so that's actually really
cool I've done Alexa skill development
before and it's super fun it's something
I definitely wanted to want to do again
and make new skills so I'm planning on
watching that that series probably will
get to it live but I'll watch the
recordings alright so let me switch up
my view there we are okay so the link to
all this code is in the description to
this video and it's on github so feel
free to take a look if you do happen to
go to get up and want to check it out
check out in the pages folder the
component called major J s that's where
we'll be at and that code should all be
up to date so it should look exactly
like I have it on my screen and what
we're what we've built so far basically
is just this so pretty pretty simple
we had some yet some issues yesterday
where we're having some errors but
finally got it to work and here's how it
looks let's go over here and this is the
wrong page let me go back and back and
back here we go
there we go okay so if you go to that
link that Ida sent you and then put in
slash education then you should see a
page like this hopefully and this
section down here is what we've created
it's a tab section and we want to
display classes so right now obviously
it functions it doesn't have all the
content needed and it doesn't really
have very much styling at all so that's
what we need to do we need to get it
some data do some styling and it extract
it into its own component so we don't
clutter up that main component too much
okay
all right so I guess the first thing
what should we do first let's let's
Express command its own she put in its
own spot yeah at this point I think
we'll be safe to do that let's take this
make it its own component and then we
can start work on the styles this is
just it's starting to get just a little
bit bigger than I that I normally like
so this is I think a nice size for a
component if you have something really
complex going on it's understandable
that you'll get bigger than this but
it's always easier to at least from my
opinion it's easier to work with smaller
file sizes and just switch back and
forth between them
okay all right so I'm gonna go in to my
components folder I can find it let's
shrink that up there we go
all right here's our components folder
and I'm gonna add a new file and let's
call this sample schedule Dutch is yeah
sample schedule j/s and I'm gonna throw
this over on this side so we'll have
them side by side and I'm I'm gonna
start out by copy and pasting everything
all right that might seem a little bit
weird like we definitely don't need
everything but I find it's easier to
copy and paste everything and then
remove what you don't need then to try
to copy and paste piece by piece so what
we'll do first is like we can get rid of
a surprise yeah let's get rid of this
first because we won't need that
we'll keep state and with the syntax
highlighting that we have sometimes
it'll help us to figure out what we need
and don't need all right so what can you
take out here we can actually we can
take out all this query stuff yeah all
of that can go so you see it's gonna be
way you know cleaner and we can get rid
of this return and even that layout
right cuz what we'll have is just this
this div here that's wrapping everything
and we'll keep these and we can get rid
of this query
and get rid of that and we definitely
can get rid of this
and in this layout and I believe we can
get rid of this as well
double check that yep so that that works
and let's change the name of this to
instead of major we're going to name we
need to name this after the component so
we'll call this sample schedule sample
schedule we don't need a yes I don't
know why it's like that
alright so sample schedule
I'm gonna save just so it'll give me the
right indentation and get rid all that
red there we go
alright great and now like I said with
that syntax highlighting it
automatically shows us what what we're
not using so now that I've taken out the
stuff in the bottom it's easy to just
remove these things we know now what we
don't need right and there we go and I
probably could do without all this they
do with thongs hmm looks that's it say
any expect consistent spacing spacing I
don't know that we need this but I'm
gonna leave it in there for now I don't
think it'll hurt anything and we
actually we don't need these styles
right now like this root style but I'm
just gonna leave it here because we're
gonna be adding some styles in alright
so now what we're left with is something
that is a lot cleaner
you know easier to deal with
oops we can take this out too forgot to
take that out
and that since we've taken that out can
we take this div no they will still need
yeah we need that in closing dev there
we go alright now we have nice and clean
just what we need if we really wanted to
we could probably extract out even more
and we'll see what happens as we build
this out if it starts to get big you
know maybe we'll do it not 100%
necessary I don't think at least not yet
so now we have our component so for
those of you who are new to react I'm
gonna go really basic here for those of
you who have used it before just you
know bear with me and be patient but now
that we have taken this out like how do
we use it in this this other component
which will be our parent component so
the first thing that we can do and we
will do is we're gonna remove a lot of
this so we get rid of that and in its
place we can just say sample schedule
okay for now we're not gonna pass any
props but eventually we will need to
pass it some data and we have this
little line depending on how you have
you added or set up you may or may not
get this line but for us we could get
this line actually I think I'm gonna
remove this link as well or that that
little code I commented out so when I go
here we can actually remove these
because those are now in this component
and we can remove these because they're
no longer needed but here we're gonna
import video we're gonna import that
sample sample scheduled component from
we're gonna go to components oops
sample schedule so now we've imported
that so all of that code is available to
us and if we go back down that line is
gone so now it will pull in all of this
so let's save it and see if we've done
it right if we've done it right we
shouldn't get an error and we should see
the same thing that we just saw at the
beginning of the stream let's check it
out and we get an error I'm gonna
refresh just to be sure okay contra
property value of no we got this we got
this yesterday major ridges yes 24 maybe
I left value in I think I did I need to
remove it there we go there's one line I
forgot to remove that we had moved over
here and that line no longer made sense
to be there so let's see if that fix the
issue
Apolo cannot be property apollo
undefined and alright let's see maybe I
do need to take out
hmm
I'm guessing it has something to do with
what I put in it all right so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna look at another
component that we've made oops that's
some data may be making another
component I just looked over I'm gonna
look over at the chat and see if anybody
caught my mistake yet before I try to
fix it here Michael asked if I started
the timer I do it's about 12 minutes
left
okay all right so I do see your comments
and I'll get to them as soon as the
timer goes up I didn't see anything
about what's going on here okay so let
me check
let's check this again see if I can see
what's happening
hmmm alright what was my oh I know what
I was going to do to try to figure out
what to do so I'm gonna look at my
components and I'm just gonna pick you
know any of them really it doesn't
matter and we'll see what we're doing
here so it looks like yeah we definitely
don't need a Paulo do we even need we
don't need with roots and so styles do
we need with data no probably not
then get rid of these and then down here
we can get rid of this there we go
all right that should should fix it so
we were basically importing and trying
to do some things here in this component
that we didn't really need to great okay
now it works we'll scroll down hey we
have the component right so here we have
your three or four awesome awesome cool
so now it's in its own component the
nice thing about this too is if we
wanted to we could reuse this today
which I'm not sure where we'll reuse it
right now but it's a large project so we
may find a use for this at some point
and if that happens all we have to do is
just import let's get rid of this just
import sample schedule and then pop it
in so I I definitely if you're doing
react I definitely recommend breaking
things out into their own components
whenever that makes sense to do it so
now that we have this kind of broken
down here what we want to do is we want
to do next I think it's actually put in
some data I think it's better to have
real data or the least realistic data
that's going to accurately represent
kind of the amount and size of the data
that you'll have before I go into
styling because some things might change
if we get a lot of stuff in there
positioning a thing it just we're not
really sure how it's gonna look until we
get the data in there so that's the next
step for that I think the easiest thing
would be to use the WordPress REST API
to just pull in some JSON data and I'll
copy and paste that you know right into
our component and then use that data
okay that's not how we'll actually do it
when we make this live but it'll be a
really quick way for us to get get
something in there and not have to type
it out ourselves
let's go over here and just close some
of these out so we can go W key we
should be able to know what is that WP
JSON I can't remember what the end point
is alright let's look up the end point
cuz I just totally can't you know what
we have in our code already we'll grab
it from our code why is there an for
just our search page where we are using
the REST API there we go there's our end
point so let's grab that and if we put
in our end point into a regular browser
will be able to see data all right so
here's a lot of data way more than we
really need but let's see if we can get
let's see if it'll be on here already
[Music]
sample course great see so it this the
screen that it gives you but you know
automatically shows you all your routes
and everything so we're gonna go to
sample courses and that I don't narrow
it down for us for a sample course and
this should give us all of the sample
courses
all right great so you see we have our
data and this is the part of the data
that I'm really worried about here so
we'll probably grab a little bit more
because I'll need the title but then
everything else you need to stay in here
let's see yeah let's just grab this one
grab the whole the whole thing and then
once we paste it will get rid of what we
don't want
so we've we should be able to just go in
here we'll make we'll call this course
data and then we're gonna make it to
make it as close as possible what we're
really going to see it's going to be an
array of objects
why is it expecting oh you know what I
accidentally I didn't realize that I was
already pasting in this bracket so let's
try that again
okay great so even though we're only
gonna have one object here like we may
end up having more than one object so
this is what we're gonna deal with so
I'm gonna remove a lot of this just to
make it easier to it to work with
there we go we want that ACF data there
we go and there we go you can get rid of
all of that what's this do we keep we
have one too many brackets here too okay
let's close maybe it's just complaining
about that unexpected so again okay I
think he was just complaining about the
trailing commas hopefully that wasn't no
still mm-hmm expected late they really
expected the comma
yeah I mean it looks okay in terms of
how many brackets we have
all right anybody see that what did I
let me take my timer all right two
minutes okay
it's in about two minutes I'll go back
and answer questions in the live chat
for now let me make this a bit bigger
here on the screen and try to figure out
what my error is
No so it's possible I messed something
up when I was copy or when I was
removing content ACF and within there's
year this would be a bit better if the
indentation was correct so let's see
actually where is this okay year it is
another array
okay that works
okay Julio says all shift f2 format
thank you it's not working for me
oh [ __ ] is it different for a Mac
oh okay what do we have now that should
match up spring semester there we go
command shift P is for okay let's try
that command shift P formats
I what is this I never I do not know
what these symbolize I can never
remember what this okay Control Alt be
great can't control I'll be I still not
formatting it all right then oh well my
times up let's do a short break I'll go
back to the chat and answer some
questions and then maybe I'll realize
what I'm doing wrong here
all right Albert Marsh says how long do
you finish this project sorry if you
answered this question before all you
had no problem the project's not ever
really going to be finished it's just
gonna have a launch date and then after
that we're gonna make updates to
different sections so a lot of what we
have on the site now is old fragments of
HTML from from the old site it's not
really ideal but we don't we don't have
time to design and develop new suffer
everything right so we want to launch
first with the content as is and then
develop but I'd like to launch by the
end of this month or I don't know like
early August so I'm gonna have I'm gonna
serve you my wrist on the 20th of July I
don't know what my recovery times gonna
be like if I could have it launched
before then that would be awesome but
then if something goes wrong I don't
really know how much I could do so I
don't know if it makes more sense to
launch before or after my surgery so I
yeah so I don't really know but I would
I would say it's it's going to be
launched within the next month it's at
some point and then after that we'll
probably work on some other projects and
this project and just kind of bounce
around unless there's some other big
thing that I'm gonna get assigned to
work on which definitely could happen
Phoenix says I'm competing with FIFA
World Cup semi-final and the transfer
news of Ronaldo from Real Madrid alright
well I've no wonder I don't have as many
viewers as I had yesterday right that's
what I'm gonna blame on the lack of
yours I'm gonna blame it on that and not
at all on me hey in this year how's it
going I feel like I haven't seen you for
a long time maybe just because I had the
vacation and everything and but I'm glad
you're here how you doing oh let me
answer your question I'm doing I'm doing
it well I actually am feeling really
well lately so but anyway how are you
doing how you doing oh no Boone savage
says hi started back on 100 days of code
again last week awesome awesome
good job with that keep us updated
see
Stephen says hi I'm new to frontin can I
get started on react yeah it depends on
how much JavaScript you know I feel a
basic understanding of JavaScript you
may be able to get started with some
basic react and just kind of learn and
build your skills up with JavaScript and
react as you go you also want a basic
understanding of HTML and CSS so the
more you understand about JavaScript
HTML and CSS before you get into react
the easier it'll be to to learn it not
impossible to learn without those things
but it's you're just gonna have to learn
them all at the same time
Albert Maher says you should update
visual studio code so you could get the
outline feature I thought I was up to
day off to check that will services this
is in response to the question about
getting started with react says if you
are really new do the free code camp
stuff then go do the 7 day free trial
treehouse web design track ok cool
yeah that's definitely good advice if
you really are starting out yeah
definitely check out free code camp I
haven't checked out anything on
treehouse so but I've heard good things
about it so check that out as well
treehouse is a paid program so you know
you can do the free trial but free code
camp if you didn't know from the name is
entirely free all right I didn't get
through everything but I'm gonna go
ahead and put start this timer again
I'll come back and any questions that I
missed this time around I'll get you
next time all right let's get back to
this this code see what I'm doing wrong
let's just try a deleting stuff and see
what we can delete
there we go this will simplify things so
now we can see that we need a closing
bracket
oops no we need to close this and to
close this right
yeah
okay not exactly correct do we need
I think we need one more bracket here
and that's gonna cover us here yep and
so then the next thing that we'll need
is actually a bracket a curly bracket
then love a regular bracket right
what happened all right and that's gonna
be there
can I read prep you know to undefined
[Music]
what are these areas for oh this is just
indentation so I should be fine what was
that thing was a ctrl alt ctrl shift B
or something like that I'll control B I
don't remember for whatever reason it's
not Auto formatting for me but it looks
like this will work since yes since
that's all indentation I'm gonna leave
it for now now we have course data so
here's where we can do some fun stuff
with the course data we can for now
we're gonna cheat a little bit just to
get some of this data in here so it'll
be slightly different when we do it you
know for real but we'll need that we
have a spot for label no we don't okay
so above all these tabs need let's do an
h2 and this is going to be we're gonna
say course data zero title rendered
laughter right this course data oh shoot
is it not
of course they've
there we go of course data zero right
because remember that's an array and
then we're gonna put its title dot
rendered okay so this should display the
title and we can I we can test that out
right away just to make sure it's
working cool here we go here's our title
all right cool
maybe you don't want it to look exactly
like that but for now at least we're
getting the data here right so we have
that data and for these tab labels for
now I'm just gonna leave them as is and
what we want to go to now is this a CF
year so we'll have this is gonna be a
little bit tricky so within within each
of these all right here's how we'll do
it
so let me let me make some some comments
here to keep it straight
so we forget that lets just code it
alright so we're gonna drop it into into
JavaScript script land here with these
curly brackets so what we put in here is
going to be JavaScript so we're gonna
take course data zero and we're gonna
say dot a CF and then within that dot a
CF will have year spring semester
forces
that's actually kind of weird do I only
have two years I must have picked one
that only had two years all right not a
problem we're only gonna have two years
for this one we can always yeah let's
just copy and paste this data more
because I'd really like to have all four
years so let's see there we go so let's
just add in another two years there we
go okay so we're gonna remove this stuff
and in here we'll go dot year right and
year is an array of objects so we can
say dot map is that year years it is
year okay so we'll just say we're gonna
say year and we're gonna make an arrow
function here and then whatever we have
inside of this arrow function is going
to be automatically returned so what we
want to return automatically then is
it's actually this this value equals
right so let's copy this for now
is it going to let me do that opening
curly brackets let's let's put in see if
this this helps so we're gonna put in
some parens here which will basically
keep up with this Otto returning let's
see
I put my friend in the wrong place so
you don't want it there I want it we're
here yeah and then one about this one
oh man he's uh you're starting to get
crazy all right so this should be yeah
these two should match up all right I'm
not getting the air anymore
great
who
[Music]
all right not sure what's going on there
don't know why it doesn't like that
might not be able to do brackets right
after so and I might not I not need to
do brackets right after I could do
alright let's get rid of this for now
to have is so within this arrow function
I still need disprin all those
formatting is getting me it's just like
it's just crazy today to figure out okay
so and then that we have and then I
should have okay so these are reversed
okay but then now
I see
no trailing spaces not allowed okay
it's that work huh are we good all right
all right cool okay so this is actually
working it looks like it's not working
but I'll explain this in a second
so it's looping through each it's
looping through that data and since we
have four objects in the year array we
have this four times right now why is it
doing all the class stuff because we
haven't actually plugged in any of the
data yet right but this just shows our
loop is working it's looping through the
data correctly
all right so it's always good to test
things like as often as you possibly can
because then it's way easier to figure
out what went wrong if you know like
okay I only changed this one line well
if you go through and change 50 lines
and then try to figure out where the
problem was
it's a lot harder to debug right all
right so now that we have that let's
change this to year and index so what
I'd like to have in here is just call it
index so it's really obvious so when you
use map your second your variable
whatever here is going to be your index
number so we need the index here because
we want to put that value in here okay
so that's going to match up to each tab
having its value and that's tied in with
our state and that's how we know when we
click on a tab it changes the state all
right and that value determines what
content is shown all right so each
container corresponds to one item in
that that index one item in that array
so let's switch this up and call this
index okay so that's going to get the
index variable now and then down here
we'll have this is where it's gonna get
tricky we're gonna have some some nested
Maps here so within this this container
div we have to well within the the grid
container actually which can we take out
this div I think we can I think we
needed this div before but we do not
need it and great so we can just go with
this grid and the lines are just for
indentation
let's pick there we go
okay so within our great container we
have two sections right to grid items
and these represent our two columns so
for each column this we're gonna have I
I think that we're always gonna have
these two columns so what we'll do is
we'll leave the columns and we'll leave
the grid items in here and we'll leave
the section and we even you leave the UL
and we'll leave the headers so we can
then go through and say year and we can
go with the index right
all right so we want to use the the
index value right to go right to that
that object in the Year array that we're
dealing with what is it is so sweet so
good there we go and then within that
let's check our data so we get the right
place so right now we're in year and
let's assume we're on 0 in the index so
in this first object now we want to say
fall semester courses right in fall
semester courses actually you know what
we right now don't have data for the
titles
all right so we can hard code these
actually we're gonna hard code them now
if we come upon a use case where we need
to put something different then maybe we
can we can do that but I believe we can
hard code this so and I messed up the
braces I just saw yeah so that wouldn't
have worked as I wrote it anyway but we
can put in for fall semester and then
let's add let's add this here so we can
do spring semester and like I said I
think this should work for everywhere
where we use this if not we can always
go back in here and make these variables
and add that in as an option for users
to enter into our WordPress you know
content management and then we'll grab
that with the rest of our data as well
but for now it should work now here is
where we need another map okay so we
want to map through and I should just
get rid of all these we're gonna map
through these these allies so we're
gonna go back into JavaScript land and
we're gonna say Year and here's what
we're gonna want to use that index and
then we're gonna say dot and what was it
fall semester courses
and dot map and now we'll say course all
right of that arrow function and we can
just have the Li and put in see the data
course
why is it like this
missing key oh yeah I definitely need a
key prop and for the key prop I'm just
gonna put it in course because we don't
we don't have anything else the courses
should be unique they're not they're not
gonna be unique
they'll be unique according to that
particular map right that so you can
also you can do a lot of different
things for your key but for now this is
what I'm going to use for this
particular key I guess it wouldn't be a
bad idea to just do course and let's go
plus index
okay we'll do it like that all right
great and then we can copy and paste
that down here and just change this to
your spring assuming I didn't a mess
right yep spring semester courses okay
let's save that see if I if I did it
right and the layers down here so far
that's good
whoops fall semester courses of
undefined all right what's undefined so
year index and I forgot to put a CF so
no wait no a CF is within the year so it
shouldn't work it just should have
maybe
is that the first time we used our index
I thought we use index here at words
maybe let me check my timer only have
another minute left maybe I have this
backwards
maybe index should be first I don't
think so but don't take a second to try
it yeah that was it
I think well let me double-check okay
well what am I getting nothing gave me
no data all right here we go can are you
property fall semester courses of
undefined let's make let's clear this
out and give it a refresh
all right this week
all right well my time is up let me give
it a five-minute break and then we'll go
back to it so we'll debug that let me
come back and I need to keep an eye ok
I'm tying on on time I need to leave in
an hour so I'd say an hour is plenty of
time for us I'm gonna scroll back up to
where I left off in the chat and just
keep on going
Phoenix's how do I get the difference
between my github repo and my local repo
I tried get diff master and they
returned nothing and then get pulled two
changes does it tell you if you if you
do get status
I don't know cuz I'm not I'm in sync
with with this one otherwise I checked I
don't remember offhand git status might
let you know if you're ahead or behind
the master branch but I'm not 100% sure
on that Christopher says you should
install plugins that automatically
import files you need so that you do not
have to keep looking stuff up all the
time you know what I I have a plug-in
like that installed on my laptop I think
so cuz I thought I had it installed
obviously I don't here so it must be on
my laptop so yeah I'll just I need to
have that in there it's not a huge deal
normally but it definitely does save a
little bit of time Stephen says stop
yawning get yourself some coffee I had
coffee I just I drank the last bit of it
but I also have G fuel so maybe I just
I'll drink some of that right now
Stephen says just Twitter message to you
some of the sites that I built check
them out let me know what you think if
the stream sees it's cool
alright cool off to check these up see
the messages
oh hey also I forgot to mention I was on
my first podcast and it was they put it
out today so I did the podcast interview
last week but if you want to check it
out just go to my Twitter I believe my
Twitter is linked in the description go
to my Twitter I did retweet the the
tweet that announced the podcast so
check it out if you get a chance let me
know what you think it's the this old
app podcast
alright I'm ringing up some of those
websites on my other screen here all
right let me go through while those load
let me go through the other questions
world says why doesn't process and dot
note him ever work for me I always have
to hard code a port 3000 or something
I'm not exactly sure I think I would
probably need more information to try to
figure out why that that's not working
all right innocence I'm doing well I'm
happy to see you
yeah for sure I'm happy to see you in
here to cat D says what happened to your
wrist did you get carpal tunnel no it's
actually I don't think it's carpal
tunnel but so last July so a year ago I
was in a swimming pool with my kids and
I was throwing them like up over my head
as high as I could right
they loved it my wife did not love it
but I just kept throwing them and
throwing them and my arms are getting
really tired so I went to throw one of
them and my muscles were just way too
relaxed and my wrist just bent back
right so you know they were like sitting
right here my wrist bent back and I just
felt its pain and I'm like I'm fine you
know so I just kept going right it hurt
a little bit but I just kept throwing
them and I let it go for a long time and
thought it'll get better
finally after like months I went to see
a doctor got x-rays they couldn't figure
out what it was sent me to a physical
therapy I did physical therapy for weeks
maybe months
I don't remember didn't get better they
sent me for more I think it was an MRI
after that couldn't figure out what
happened gave me an injection that made
me feel better for about two weeks and
then I said all right well I'm just I'm
gonna let it go I'm too busy now because
the next step was surgery and I say love
you know I have too much going on so I
let it go for months before I contacted
the doctor again it takes forever to get
in to see this doctor because the doctor
is in Pittsburgh and if I go to
Pittsburgh to see the doctor my
insurance won't cover it but like once a
month the doc
comes to where I live Steubenville and
if I see him when he comes to
Steubenville my insurance covers it so
every time I go to make an appointment
with the surgeon I have to wait like two
months to get in so went back to him and
finally said okay let's do the surgery
so then to try to schedule the surgery
of course took forever so I'd schedule
it like I don't know like four months in
advance or something crazy so anyway
they're gonna go in and just try to
figure out what's wrong with my wrist so
I think they're gonna cut my wrist open
put a little camera in there figure out
what's wrong and then I don't know what
will happen if it's if it's minor and
they can fix it right then they're gonna
fix it so I'm I don't know what to
expect in terms of recovery time or
because they just haven't been able to
figure out what's what's actually wrong
with it so anyway sorry for the long
story of my my wrist hurting but I just
I mean I it may be that I can type in
everything after it I don't really know
just have no idea what what to expect
all right cool i actually got through
everything i went over a little bit on
time here let's reset this timer and
we'll do I don't know if we'll need this
whole Pomodoro session or not but we'll
reset it just in case I can't get this
working and I see gifted fingers says
hello from Detroit hey how's it going
welcome alright so we were okay
it wasn't finding the data correct is
that the problem
yeah no we're not getting errors right
we're not even getting errors are we
getting errors here I thought we'd get
an error message
that's weird all right let me check what
I have here okay so this part no it's
not even working returned all right it
did work before I put this in this in it
it did work right it displayed things
four times
I see okay all right let me think about
this
okay so I don't
all right let's let's see if there's
anything there at all
so inspected just went close to yours
alright looks like there's nothing else
there at all
let's check react
I so index
sexy a little bit odd
hmmm alright so I think the issue is
with what we're doing here let's let's
just take this out quickly just to
verify that that is actually where the
the issue is can I read fall semester
courses I'm undefined
Christopher Brown says you have index
and year in the wrong spots okay so we
did we did flip this oh that's right
okay so I forgot that we flipped that
just to test it out and I don't think
that was the problem I was like that
yeah the same same thing
hmm
missing key prop yeah I should put a key
prop here and we can just call this I
really wanted to be
oh okay Christopher you you are right
I don't think we need to do index so I'm
not sure what I was thinking let's see
if that makes a difference objects are
not Valadez react shallow found objects
with keys of course 48
oh okay that's an object can just do
course it needs to be wait a second
Oh course dot course I need to of course
dark horse
oh yeah okay so we got them now
all right yeah good good eye on that
Christopher I remember putting that year
in there but I can't remember why I did
yeah it's at some point I thought you're
just gonna I don't know what I was
thinking but anyway yeah we don't the
whole point of the map is that you don't
have to mess with like manually doing
the the index on those things anyway all
right so let's try what we had again
over here which was value so we had this
return and then with in the return we
were trying to get value you goes index
and
and then we're trying to return whatever
that is
okay so spaces inside so we're trying to
find out if the value is equal to the
index then we're gonna render that now
I'm not I don't think this is gonna work
but we'll try whoa it worked awesome
all right that's really cool what I was
afraid would happen is that it would
take when it rendered this it would just
say the value of index is zero so we'll
render here but then the next time
through the value of index actually
now that I think about it this worked
out really well and I don't I don't know
why I worked out so well
you thought you lose index yeah I don't
know anyway it works that's all that
matters
so it works how I hoped it would or not
how I thought it would okay all right
what's the key yeah
all right so right now we are having an
issue with with our keys with the same
keys so that's happening because we we
do have these duplicate courses so and
you know we're not gonna get away from
that because we have elective elective
elective and I think we'll probably end
up having a lot of stuff like this so we
need to use something else as the key
like what we could use you see in the
data you know we're not really getting
anything that could help us in terms of
each each one of these like a unique ID
or anything so we could do cages UUID
you I there we go
okay so we can use UUID to create a
unique ID so let's try that and Wow
there are a lot of versions of this
anyway
let's let's install this so let's go and
for yarn add UUID and now we should be
able to bring in UUID require
I don't know what's up with all these
different versions our version one is a
time stand
my name is phase version four is random
he says
what happened aversion to the 1 3 4 5
all right
he says view has UUID built in each
component oh that's pretty cool all
right
that's squares values and
would you stir this in to the key
see this works
cool at work so we have unique IDs our
unique keys let's check and react so our
key is we've taken the name of the
course we could probably get rid of that
that's that's a loan key these should be
unique so we can see each one of these
so I'm looking up here in the corner
each one of these is a unique ID so
let's do it just to clean things up a
little bit let's take out course and now
we just have this unique ID cool and
that gets rid of all those ugly warnings
and in the console cool alright so we
have our data the the data that we have
here in this format is the exact format
that we will get it and if we go with
the REST API which is our fallback
ideally we're going to try to get this
data through graph QL but having trouble
working with modifying the PHP of our
plugins to make that happen
so this is our fallback so we're pretty
much all set the only thing that we'd
really have to change is we would have
to change the course data instead of
just going with course state of 0 we
would kind of have another layer of map
right so we would map over every object
in course data essentially we'd wrap
this entire thing in another map and so
we could have potentially have you know
multiple of all of this you know on the
same the same page so that would really
be the only thing we need to change and
so now let's let's
get some some styling so I want to just
shrink this down to a smaller width so
we get an idea how this looks on mobile
and the first thing I'm noticing is I I
don't really know that I want this to be
a in h2 I think that's kind of like
overkill what's up here I'm not able I'm
not able to move yeah let's let's switch
it up and yeah that's looking okay there
we go
all right so if we actually do go into
device simulator here all right it's
it's better there we go
so it just does move all right so here's
what I'm seeing this could probably
stand to drop down
- an h3 and then we could drop these two
H fours and I think that would make
sense with the the hierarchy of the of
the page so let's do that now let's get
rid of that I don't need that
alright yes we're gonna make this in h3
and then drop these ones to H fours and
let's see what that gives us now okay
alright that's okay I think that's
that's good
I think this is way too much space in
between these two so let's do that and I
also want to get rid of these bullet
points so now we're going to actually
get into our styles so we can on these
allies we can turn it's a style
yeah maker Styles up here styles dot
list item and now let's go up here and
make let's remove this roots and make
list item right so this is one way to do
styles in react okay so it's gonna be a
javascript object and we're gonna put in
what is very similar to normal CSS but a
little bit different so list style
I believe that's that's what this is
list outside none let's see if that
works great that works so we've gotten
rid of this and then we can see let's
switch back to the element here and we
can now see on our allies oops
there we go
upon our allies it has lists outside
none so it's actually transferred that
style to an inline style that's pretty
cool and it's the fact that it's an
inline style is really cool in terms of
like performance when it when all this
is rendered server-side and the user
gets that first load and that that first
load they get is going to be just
server-side rendered straight HTML you
know it's you're not waiting for a
stylesheet to load to get this so I mean
it definitely has some advantages that
way and it doesn't require you to
manually go in and add those inline
Styles alright cool so we have that the
second thing we want to do is we're
going to reduce the the padding just
kind of all around right I don't think
we need we don't need as much padding
here we don't need as much here and we
don't need as much here so what is our
issue maybe the section oh you know what
I forgot to add in section here so we're
dealing with different markup for these
and it shouldn't be different ok there
we go let's see if that made any
difference
doesn't look like it for style okay so
let's make some some changes here in dev
tools and then we can transfer them over
in our component so there we go so these
you elves have quite a bit of of margin
or I mean sorry padding where are we
getting that padding from
there we go yeah we're gonna set that
padding to zero and let's see what that
looks like
whoops yeah let's sit up adding to zero
now for are you ELLs so it'll be the
first thing we add here
so are you ELLs are gonna get style just
like the Allies then we'll say style
equals Styles dot list and list see
we're just adding another item here and
so now it should apply to both of these
yep there we go and what is giving us
this huge amount of padding here on top
of it's not section all right so ul does
come with some margin that we could
probably get rid of who wins that H tag
has quite a bit of margin so
I wonder what would be better you know
what let's try to get rid of the margin
on these lists first just because we
have it already set up this new margin:0
nope we need a comma okay so that
brought us closer but I still think this
h4 is just way too much padding both
above and below I'm sorry margin both
above and below so let's see margin
let's say from like four pixels is zero
that's better I think we might be able
to go down
okay what
okay and then these these days which are
grids they also have padding
alright but let's let's throw that
margin on here so let's say list header
is going to be margin for see if we can
do it like this for zero
it's not working
no it didn't work because I didn't put
it on there didn't actually give any any
style to this age for style Michael I
just saw that you mentioned to me about
the section tag thing I'm sorry I didn't
see that but thanks for for letting me
know about it okay so our style is
Tedder oops I forgot the equals can
always tell when you did something wrong
when you get weird highlighting whoops
and that's supposed to be Stiles not
something just made a noise use
messaging me
make sure it's not for work I don't
think it is so they were good okay
whoa okay it worked but that's not
exactly what I wanted
Oh
okay
all right maybe we'll decrease on these
on these grid items
will decrease the bottom padding to zero
see how that looks
this grid
this grid item gonna be that I was patty
wasn't it
padding-bottom this is easier okay
all right it's better I I don't really
like the padding here let's quickly
check how this is affected okay okay so
not not terrible probably just need a
little bit more here but I think what
I'll do to achieve that is add add to
whatever this container is for our tabs
and we'll add in margin bottom and let's
say a pixels oh no did that move the it
moved the underline down okay so that's
not what we want what we need then is
perhaps the container
the grid container is what needs a
padding top of 8 pixels there we go
that's a lot nicer so let's do that
this grid container it's gonna give
we're gonna put a padding top of 8 8
pixels and there's that good there we go
style
Styles thoughtless gridded container
all right I the only other thing that I
think would be good to do is move these
tabs over so I'm not sure what's no
that's not it it's the the tabs and
stuff there we are okay this is what we
want
yeah what is this oh it's a space for
the button that's why
the skier rid of this buttons and
can I go none I don't know if none is
the right thing to put on there we'll
see in a second
okay that's that's better
okay this is acceptable right now I
wouldn't say like it's perfect but it's
definitely acceptable okay sorry about
that I definitely went over my 25-minute
timer on that one but it was just so
close to getting it to - look I don't I
I think presentable at least at some
point you amazed my experience there's
always something some adjustment you can
make at some point you just have to say
like okay this is good enough and and
just stop because otherwise you like
nitpick at these tiny details and if you
have the time on the project to do that
that's okay but I definitely don't okay
great so before I go to the rest of the
questions I want to commit this
so we'll do it's good we we just worked
on this file but we did also change
these and we added this one so you'll
get ad will do yarn CM and that's our
little helper to help us make nice
nicely formatted you commit messages so
this is a new feature and let's say it
is add create sample schedule component
and no breaking changes it does effect
an open issue and this would be
regarding issue number 102 I think
that's what we had yesterday we'll go
with that and that's it it should run
through all the tests do some Auto
formatting some testing and then we'll
be able to push that up and then all the
code will be available and get up if you
want to check that out it will be there
for you all open source free for you to
do whatever you need to with it
awesome everything worked and would it
get push and that's that the next step
notice I didn't close that issue because
we still have one more step and that's
actually pulling in real data so that
you know that was real data at least
part of it what we got was real but we
need to dynamically pull that in based
on the URL so that'll be a little bit
more tricky than what we dealt with
today but that would be the next step so
I may or may not stream that step we'll
just we'll see how it goes alright let
me get to the chat and answer all your
remaining questions
oh wow not that many questions that okay
that's actually not bad because I do
have to leave in maybe 15 minutes or
less all right Michael Michael ed the
same idea with as me add the bottom
margin to the tab header yeah
unfortunately it it didn't work and the
reason being like this seems like it's a
border but it's not actually a bottom
border this is an entirely separate
element HTML element and that's how we
get this effect of it moving
right if this was just the border on the
bottom it would just immediately move
there would be no transition but we're
seeing this transition here right and
that's because it's it's actually you
know an element you're kind of moving
through there so if it was just a border
margin bottom would have actually worked
okay let's see Stephen says two days of
to our streams what what don't forget to
check out my sites just want to know if
I'm progressing well I do have a
creative department so I'm strictly web
design okay cool yeah well I'm gonna
take a look at those maybe right now on
the on the stream all right Christopher
Brent brown said you should do a
material list yeah you know what we
checked out yesterday using the list
component and material UI and we decided
not to because it thought we could just
use the simple UL li if there's some
reason why using the list component for
material you I would make more sense
here I'm definitely open to it but for
now I just didn't think that I I needed
that
okay let me check out these sites
all right these are cool I'm gonna bring
them over onto the screen so we can all
check out these sites so this is these
are Stephens sites
let's just let's make them fullscreen
this one okay cool
so Wow I really like these alright and
these are WordPress awesome so
stephenie's are then like WordPress
theme theme work very cool
cool
nice this is nice theme for for
Pittsburgh new definitely has those
Pittsburgh sports teams colors going on
there like that and
that's cool I like this map
you know I noticed though I'm not sure
if it's something up with with my
computer or whatever but it does that
there's no labels
there's no labels to see what the fill
in here which I mean I can based on the
auto you know complete it does it but
and then this text is really small but
other than that I really like I like how
this looks I love this call-to-action
button up here the shadows on that are
nice and I love this style button as
well very cool cool icons I even like
the e these have like a subtle shadow
cool once I love these V style button I
always call these inverted buttons I
don't remember where I got that from but
I always I kind of like that
very cool that's a nice background I
said that's a nice touch
really really cool
Wow so you did a site for a company in
Houston Portland and Pittsburgh all over
the place huh that's that's awesome
anyway Stephen I'm super impressed with
these sites they're beautiful they're
really nice so that's great that's
really great font size 16
the only thing I would say is maybe
consider bumping the font size up a bit
on maybe to 18 if it fits if it works
out I know this I'm on a really big
screen right now so this is probably not
the same experience that most users
would have on a on a standard screen if
there even is such a thing but that's
really the only thing that I would say
is that the font looks a little small
like I love this size font I think
that's great but these fonts look at
just a bit small wow so cool so I'm not
gonna go through all the other stuff in
the sites but usually you put the most
work into the front page anyway but wow
that's really great work that's great
work I'm like I'm palm Doug I just I
love those sites all right I think I've
gone through everything if I happen to
miss your question I apologize you can
always ask you a question in the
comments and I'll check that out
I don't always catch up on all the
comments as as much as I would like to
so if it's a really pressing thing you
can always DM me on Twitter or on
Instagram or send me a message on
facebook or whatever okay see this is
the amenities page is another big one
with a lot of customizations
so we'll check that out - oh nice look
at that that's cool that's really cool
effect if I would if I can recommend
something with that effect
I might just slow it down a little bit I
really like it but I think it would be
cooler if it was a little bit slower and
that may just be like my extreme motion
sickness coming into play here that it's
just too fast for me but other than that
that's cool I love that I'm assuming on
mobile that it would be so I don't see
how that how that works okay cool so
it's touch nice
cool that's really cool I like that
alright see you said yeah I need to
figure out the transition speed that's
next on my list
cool yeah and like I said I mean it
looks good and it might just be me the
mobile click but it's having some issues
as well yeah I noticed it's yeah but I
mean I think it's overall the look is
just really really really good I think
that's amazing look for like for those
particular businesses and what what that
type of business needs to convey to
their audience I think it's perfect the
sites look really like upscale very
clean and I think that that definitely
appeals to who it seems like they're
their target audience would be oh I
didn't even notice you could do open all
that's cool I really love that feature
that's cool I'm gonna remember this
feature if I had to do any list like
this of the open Hall that's super
useful all right you know okay I
definitely have to hit the quit this
dream now because I don't want to be
late
actually I have a haircut that's what I
need to go to have an appointment for a
haircut so I don't not not the end of
the world if I am late for my haircut
but you know I don't want to be late for
the haircut there's people that you know
that are hairdressers like they have
their schedule in their appointments
you're late you set them back then
everybody else after you is set back in
there playing catch-up so it's not it's
not polite right to be late so anyway
I'm trying to be there on time so thank
you all so much for watching and for all
your help definitely a lot of you were
helping I know Christopher stood out
today especially more than more than at
any other point and in your help as well
and there are a lot of you that are
always that helpful that we're helping
out as well I definitely appreciate that
and check out my podcast
so check out my Twitter and you'll see a
link to one of my last Suites was about
the podcast that I did and let me know
what you think it was my first time on a
podcast so I'm sure I could have done
better but hopefully it's entertaining
or informative for some people so I'm
gonna try to stream earlier tomorrow so
maybe like 11:30 noon something like
that depends on how my meetings go but
I'd like to do something in that in that
range and then get a stream in before
that Amazon Alexa skills livestream
that'll be at 1:00 p.m. Eastern time so
hopefully I'll see y'all tomorrow and
until then have a wonderful day